question if I asked you to prove to me
that you were a safe driver how would
you do it would you point to how long
you've been driving without a crash
maybe how many miles you've driven or
maybe you tell me about some risky
moments you'd navigated and survived
well that conundrum how to prove that
you're safe is exactly what autonomous
driving companies are trying to solve
right now let me explain
see you may have seen driverless
Vehicles out practicing on real roads as
these companies try and teach their
self-driving algorithms to deal with as
many different challenges as possible
and in that process some of them have
had accidents but the problem is no
matter how many real world miles they
drive it's unlikely they'll encounter
some of the weird rare events that
they're trying to test against and some
they really wouldn't want to these
incidents are called edge cases once in
a lifetime events that might completely
throw off a driverless algorithm if it
isn't trained properly so to get around
this conundrum autonomous driving
companies are building simulated driving
schools where their AI can safely drive
billions of miles and learn to deal with
some of the most bizarre scenarios you'd
ever find on the road so what do virtual
driving schools look like and what kind
of tests are they running well to find
out a little bit more about simulation I
got in touch with autonomous Trucking
Company Aurora after all they've created
this simulated environment Yep this
isn't real we realized that if we were
going to actually ship a self-driving
vehicle we couldn't just drive a bunch
of miles on the road if you look at the
rate at which people have accidents it's
low enough that if you really want to
understand it you're going to have to
simulate it that's Chris Emerson
Aurora's CEO who told me that they hired
physicists and even Academy
award-winning software Engineers to
create their perception training
environment we've built an engine that
is hyper realistic uh but incredibly
repeatable the idea is that their
algorithm the Aurora driver thinks that
it's in the real world but its sensors
are actually connected to this simulated
environment where Aurora can load a
whole different range of problems for
the truck to try and perceive now this
perception environment is actually one
of the more detailed training
environments that Aurora uses the
company also uses far simpler ones to
allow them to test vehicle logic and
decision making talking at a rapid pace
so we can spin up the equivalent of 50
000 trucks if something interesting
happens out there we're able to convert
that real world thing into a simulation
and it's not just Aurora far from it
driverless companies like waymo and
Crews also have their own simulators too
as well as startups like Wabi who have
created a simulation engine that allows
them to drop fake Vehicles into
real-world environments and even have
those Vehicles react to the actions of
the algorithm itself creating a virtual
feedback loop but here's the interesting
question once you've built a virtual
environment that can test against edge
cases which edge cases do you test
against after all in a virtual world you
could program literally anything to
happen you could make elephants fall
from the sky but if you tested your
algorithm against literally everything
you'd waste a lot of time and computing
power testing against things that were
statistically impossible well one
company who believes that they have the
answer to that question is london-based
startup d-risk d-risk isn't making an
autonomous vehicle but they're trying to
create a comprehensive map of edge cases
that autonomous vehicle algorithms can
test and improve against to understand
what that actually means I sat down with
de-risk's CEO chest Stetson what we do
is first catalog everything that can
happen we do that by taking data from
all the sources that can tell us about
real life accidents so we have roughly a
million hours of camera data from a
variety of locations uh we've got
hundreds of thousands of accent reports
we have thousands of reports that we got
from Individual contributors we put them
in one massive catalog which is called a
Knowledge Graph and then we pipe those
into simulation now the edge case is
that d-risk have cataloged are certainly
odd things like porta potties falling
off trucks or picnic tables in the
middle of Highways the idea is that
driverless vehicle companies could plug
these edge cases into their simulators
to test against them de-risk can then
assess how well the algorithm them
handled certain types of scenarios and
because the company groups similar but
different edge cases they can see if the
algorithm truly understands how to
handle a problem or if it's only able to
solve the one scenario it was given
literally the difference between knowing
and understanding the company hopes that
that means that their data could be used
to help create an autonomous driving
test something that currently doesn't
exist and the hope is that this testing
environment that we've built will end up
being used to always test every new
generation of a self-driving car now
training against porta-potties and
picnic tables in the road may seem a tad
pointless after all these events are
supposed to be Niche once in a lifetime
incidents but chess believes that by
solving the hard problems you
automatically solve the easy ones if you
can learn to thread a needle then it's
really easy to thread a basketball hoop
but not vice versa so does this ever
mean we could hit a point where
driverless cars don't need to test or
practice on real roads and those crash
statistics could become a thing of the
past well according to chess it's
possible I think that is exactly the
premise that you shouldn't need to test
in an open road when you deploy it
because you should be so confident in
this Behavior but Aurora's Chris
Anderson views things a different way so
we think you need to be doing both and I
think this is very akin to the way that
we develop cars today most of the crash
testing for a vehicle happens in
simulation and then we do so some small
amount of testing in the real world to
validate it one thing is certain though
is autonomous vehicle companies try and
develop their self-driving algorithms
their cars are going to keep
encountering weird stuff both off and on
the road
[Music]